>>> AN AMAZING CONVERSATION BY A
MAN WHO HAS LED AN AMAZING LIFE.
AT THE CENTER FOR AMERICAN
CULTURE FOR DECADES.
COVID HAD AN EFFECT ON HIS LIFE
AND HE HAS THOUGHTS ABOUT IT.
HERE IS THAT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION.
>> DID WATCHING COVID IN THE
MEDICAL ESTABLISHMENTS RESPONSE
TO COVID OVER TWO YEARS CHANGE
YOUR VIEW?
>> I MEAN, THAT WAS A PIECE OF
IT.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> SPECIFICALLY, I WILL LEAN
INTO THE BLACK CONDITION JUST
FOR BEING A BLACK PERSON.
WE HAVE BEEN GETTING KILLED IN
HOSPITALS FOR YEARS.
AND DON'T COME OUT.
WE HAVE BEEN GETTING KILLED WITH
OUR FOOD TO START OFF WITH.
WE HAVE BEEN GETTING KILLED BY
POLICE OFFICERS.
EVERY DAY WE HAVE BEEN KILLING
EACH OTHER.
IN THE STREETS EVERY DAY.
I FELT LIKE THE PEOPLE AT THE
GAP KNEW ABOUT THE SCHOOL
SHOOTING THAT MATTHEW
MCCONAUGHEY WAS TALKING ABOUT
BEFORE IT EVEN HAPPENED.
IT WAS SO IN SYNC, THE
INFORMATION.
AND THEN I HEARD ABOUT IT ON THE
RADIO DRIVING.
AND I IN THE TRUMAN SHOW RIGHT
NOW?
I TELL CANDACE SHE HAS GOT TO
WATCH THE TRUMAN SHOW.
STACK WHAT DO YOU MEAN THE
PEOPLE AT THE GAP KNEW ABOUT THE
SCHOOL SHOOTING.
YOU MEAN UVALDE, TEXAS?
>> I AM NOT SAYING THAT THEY
DID, BUT IT FELT SO IN SYNC,
THIS IDEA OF THIS MEDIA RUSH
OVER THE 78 SPECIFIC OUTLETS
THAT INFLUENCE.
>> THERE IS A COORDINATED
MESSAGE IS WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
>> YEAH.
MEANWHILE, THERE IS THE SAME
AMOUNT OF KIDS GETTING KILLED IN
CHICAGO EVERY WEEK, BUT THERE IS
NO COORDINATED MESSAGE ABOUT
THAT.
HAVE I REACHED ALEX STRONG'S
TERRITORY YET?
>> YOU ARE TELLING THE TRUTH.
THAT'S OKAY IF YOU DO.
>> WHAT I AM SAYING IS THEY KEEP
ON USING THE HE'S CRAZY, HE'S
CRAZY THING AND IT HURTS MY
FEELINGS WHEN PEOPLE SAY THAT.
IT HURTS MY FEELINGS THAT PEOPLE
CAN ASK ME, ARE YOU OKAY?
ESPECIALLY LIKE, I GOT AN EGO.
SOMEONE LESS SUCCESSFUL THAN ME
HAVING THE RIGHT TO ASK ME ABOUT
ME LIKE THEY ARE A [ BLEEP ]
DOCTOR?
DO YOU WANT ME TO PUT SOME ICE
ON IT.
PUT SOME ICE ON MY BRAIN AND
THAT WILL FIX IT?
EVERYONE'S GOT THE SOLUTION.
PUT SOME ICE ON IT.
DO YOU KNOW IF THAT WORKED WE
DIDN'T NEED HOSPITALS.
WE WOULD HAVE ICE DENS FOR
EVERYTHING.
GRANDMA HAS GOT CANCER.
PUT SOME ICE ON THE CANCER.
I AM FUNNIER THAN COMEDIANS.
>> BUT YOU GET THAT A LOT.
PEOPLE WITH THE KIND OF FAUX
SYMPATHY?
ARE YOU OKAY?
>> YEAH.
BUT YOU GET THAT EVEN AS A
FAMOUS PERSON.
GO BEFORE ME.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
IT'S HARD FOR PEOPLE TO EVEN
LISTEN TO YOU.
OH MY GOD, THIS IS YE.
DID YOU HEAR WHAT HE SAID AGAIN?
THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT IN MY ORGANIZATION
WHERE IT'S THEIR JOB TO NOT
LISTEN TO ME.
>> IN YOUR OWN ORGANIZATION?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THAT KIND OF THING CAN DRIVE YOU
WHAT?
>> CRAZY.
>> MY RESOLUTION THIS YEAR WAS
TO ONLY TALK TO PEOPLE WHO
LISTENED TO ME.
I KNOW, CRAZY CONCEPT.
I KNOW THAT IS CRAZY.
>> HOW RADICALLY DID THAT SHRINK
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE YOU TALK
TO?
>> NOT ENOUGH.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
THEY SEND THE BOSS AND.
THEIR PEOPLE WORKING HERE.
PRINCE HAD TO CONSTANTLY FIRE
PEOPLE I HAVE TO CONSTANTLY FIRE
PEOPLE.
ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE SITTING
AROUND DOING NOTHING.
I HAD 530 CONSULTANTS LAST YEAR.
>> FOR YOUR BUSINESSES?
>> FOR MY BUSINESS IS.
WE HIRED SOME GUYS IN.
THIS IS THE ISSUE WHEN YOU HIRE
ATHEISTS.
I THINK THAT'S ILLEGAL TO SAY IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT SUE ME.
THIS IS THE ISSUE.
GOD-FEARING PEOPLE PERFORM FOR
AN AUDIENCE OF O